let's try to solve a more involved
equation so let's say that we have let's
say that we have let me think I'm good
say we have 2 X plus 3 2 X plus 3 is
equal to is equal to 5 X is equal to 5 X
minus 2 so this might look a little
daunting at first we have X's on both
sides equations we're adding and
subtracting numbers how do you solve it
now we'll do it a couple of different
ways the the important thing to remember
is we just want to isolate an X once
you've isolated and actually have x
equals something or x equals something
you have you're done you've solved the
equation you can actually go back and
check whether that works so what we're
gonna do is just do a bunch of
operations on both sides of the equation
to eventually isolate the X but while we
do those I actually want to visualize
what's occurring cuz I don't want you to
just say oh what are the rules or the
steps of solving equations and I forgot
whether this is a lot or that isn't
allowed if you visualize what's
happening it'll actually be common sense
what's allowed so let's visualize it so
we have 2x right here on the left-hand
side so that's literally that's X plus X
and then you have plus 3 plus 3 I'll do
it like this so that's equivalent to
plus 1 plus 1 plus 1 that's the same
thing as 3 I could have drawn 3 circles
here as well but let me do the same
color plus 3 and then that is equal to 5
X's I'll do that in blue that is equal
to 5 X's so 1 2 3 4 5 and I want to make
it clear you would never actually have
to do it this way when you're solving
the problem you would just have to do
the algebraic steps but I'm doing this
for you so you can actually visualize
what this equation is saying the
left-hand side is these two orange X's
plus 3 the right-hand side is 5x minus 2
so minus 2 we could write as minus so
let me do this in a different color I'll
do it in pink so minus 2 I'll do as
minus 1 and minus 1 now we want to
isolate the X's on on the same side of
the equation so how could we do that
well there's two ways of doing it we
could subtract
these two exes from both sides of the
equation and that would be pretty
reasonable because then you'd have five
X's minus the two x's you would have a
positive number of X's on the right-hand
side or you could actually subtract 5x
from both sides and that's what's neat
about algebra as long as you do
legitimate operations you will
eventually get the right answer so let's
just start off subtracting 2x from both
sides of the equation and what I mean
that I mean we're gonna remove two X's
from the left hand side and if we remove
two hat exits from the left hand side we
have to remove two x's from the right
hand side just like that so what does
that give us we're subtracting 2 X's 2
XS from the left and we're also going to
subtract 2 X's from the right now what
is what does our left hand side simplify
to we have 2x + 3 minus 2x the two x's
cancel out so you're just left with
you're just left with the 3 and you see
that over here we took two of these X's
away we're just left with the plus 1
plus 1 plus 1 and then on the right hand
side 5x minus 2x we do have it over here
with five X's minus 2 X's you only have
one two three X's left over three is
equal to 3x and then you have your minus
2 there you have your minus 2 so
normally if you were to do the problem
you just have to write what we have here
on the left hand side so what can we do
next remember we want to isolate the X's
but we have all of our X's on the right
hand side right here if we could get rid
of this negative two off of the right
hand side then it the x's will be alone
they'll be isolated so how can we get
rid of this negative two or if we
visualize it over here this negative one
this negative 1 well we could add 2 to
both sides of this equation
think about what happens there so if we
add two so I'm going to do it like this
plus 1 plus 1 so you can literally see
we're adding 2 and then we're gonna add
2 to the left hand side 1 plus 1 plus
what happens well let me do it over here
as well so we're gonna add 2 we're gonna
add 2 so what happens to the left hand
side 3 plus 2 is going to be equal to 5
and that is going to be equal to 3 X
minus 2 plus 2 these guys cancel out and
you're just left with 3x and we see it
over here
we the left hand side is one plus one
plus one plus one plus one we have five
ones or five and the right-hand side we
have the three X's right over there and
then we have the negative one negative
one plus one plus one negative one
these cancel out they get us to zero
they cancel out so we're just left with
five is equal to three X so we have one
two three four five is equal to three X
let me clear everything that we've
removed so it looks a little bit so it
looks a little bit cleaner let me clear
that out and then let me clear these are
all of the things that we've removed let
me clear that out and then let me clear
that out like that edit clear so now we
are just left with one two three four
five lectures let me move this over so
edit cut edit paste so I could just move
this over right over here we now have we
don't have 1 2 3 4 5 these are the two
that we added here is equal to three X's
these guys cancelled out that's why we
have nothing there now to solve this we
just divide both sides of this equation
by 3 and this is going to be a little
hard to visualize over here but if we
divide over here both sides by 3 what do
we get we divide the left by 3 we divide
the right by 3 the whole reason why we
divided by 3 is because the X was being
multiplied by 3 3 is the coefficient on
the X fancy word it literally just means
the number multiplying the variable the
number we're solving the variable we're
solving for
so these threes cancel out the
right-hand side of the equation is just
X the left hand side is 5/3
so 5/3 we could say X is equal to 5/3
and this is different than everything
we've seen so far I now have the X on
the right hand side the value on the
left hand side that's completely fine
this is the exact same thing as saying
5/3 is equal to X is the same thing as
saying X is equal to 5/3 completely
equivalent completely equivalent we
sometimes get more used to this one but
this is completely the same thing now if
we wanted to write this as a mixed
number if we want to write this as a
mixed number 3 goes into 5 one time with
remainder 2 so it's going to be 1 & 2
Thirds so it's going to be one and two
thirds so we could also write that X is
equal to one and two thirds and I'll
leave it up for you to actually
substitute back into this original
equation and see that it works out now
to visualize it over here you know how
did you get one in two thirds let's
think about it instead of doing one I'm
gonna do circles I am going to do
circles actually even better I'm gonna
do squares so I'm gonna have five
squares on the left-hand side I'll do it
in this same yellow color right here so
I have one two three four five and that
that is going to be equal to the three
X's X plus X plus X now we're dividing
both sides of the equation by three
we're dividing both sides of the
equation by three actually that's where
we did up here we divide both sides by
three so how do you do that right hand
side is pretty straightforward you want
to divide these three X's into three
groups
that's one two three groups one two
three now how do you divide five into
three and when they have to be thought
through even groups and here tell them
the answer tells us each group is going
to be one in two thirds so one and two
thirds this is going to be two thirds of
this next one and then we're gonna have
one in two thirds so this is one-third
we're gonna need another another one so
there's one in one-third we're gonna
need one more of thirds so it's gonna be
right here and then we're left with 2/3
and one
so we've broken it up into three groups
this right here let me make it clear let
me make it clear this right here is one
and two thirds one and two thirds and
then this right here this is one-third
that's another one-third so that's two
thirds and then that's one right there
so that's one and two thirds and then
finally this is two thirds and this is
one so this is 1 and 2/3 so when you
divide both sides by 3 you get 1 and 2/3
each each section each each bucket is 1
and 2/3 on the left-hand side on the
left-hand side or 5/3 and on the
right-hand side we just have an X so it
still works a little bit harder to
visualize with fractions